it is seven o'clock good to have you
with us this morning another twist in
what is a terrible tale uh the next
prime minister leaving the black door
behind me wide open uh for Rishi sunak
could he get the keys to number 10 in
the coming hours after Boris Johnson
removed his hat from The Ring Penny
Morton is just the only person standing
in Rishi sunax way but her numbers are a
long way off on today's show I'll be
speaking to the Home Secretary and Rishi
sunak supporter Grant chaps Andrea
ledson from Team modern Andy Shadow
attorney general Emily Thornbury it is
Monday the 24th of October
eyes on the prize uh Rishi sunak you
know the clear front runner to be the
new prime minister after Boris Johnson
pulls out of the race
shock exit
its shock exit from the former prime
minister Boris Johnson last night he
said it is simply not the right time
because you can't govern without a
United party
two horse race British sunlight leads
with more than 150 MPS publicly backing
him compared to Penny Morgan's 25 which
she made me cut I will Rishi be prime
minister
blackouts in Kiev we report from
Ukraine's capital city as the lights go
out
warning shots North and South Korea
exchange fire
along their disputed seed boundary
I'm here in Kiev as Ukraine starts again
after an evening and a night of rolling
blackouts across this country caused by
Russian attacks on Ukraine's critical
infrastructure
get boosted millions are being urged to
have winter vaccines I'll be speaking to
the deputy chief medical officer from
England to find out exactly where we're
at with covert
battered by heavy rain and thunderstorms
parts of Southern England have woken up
to flooded roads and trees blocking
Railways we'll bring you the weather
until later on
[Music]
morning all Rishi sunak is closing in on
number 10. it is possible possible that
the former Chancellor could be announced
as the next conservative leader as early
as this afternoon that after a somewhat
shocking exit from the race from Boris
Johnson who said no is not the right
time for him to lead the party and that
you can't govern unless a party is
United now that leaves Penny mordent as
the only other candidate but of course
she is trailing behind in the number of
MPS who've publicly supported her so far
let's take a closer look at the numbers
will Rishi sunak he currently has the
public support of 154 conservative MPS
almost half the Parliamentary party
just 25 MPS have said they'll support
penny more than although she will now be
hoping that Boris Johnson supporters can
perhaps keep her in the race
uh well in the last few minutes Penny
Morton has tweeted this in taking this
difficult decision last night Boris
Johnson has put country before party and
party before self he worked to secure
the Mandate and the majority we now
enjoy we should put it to good use and I
know that he will work with us to do so
uh well as mentioned a new leader could
take office in just a few hours time
nominations will those close at two
o'clock this afternoon candidates well
they've got to secure a hundred
nominations from MPS if they are to make
the ballot if Rishi sunak is the only
Contender that reaches that Mark by two
o'clock he will become a party leader
today and of course the new prime
minister
now if pennymords into managers to
squeeze onto the ballot and there are
two candidates Tory MPS will hold an
indicative vote between half past three
and a half past five this afternoon uh
giving them the opportunity to get a
clear signal to the membership as to
their choice
uh but and again bearing in mind this is
only if there are two candidates it is
conservative party members who will then
get the final say in an online vote
which closes at 11 A.M on Friday the
results well it will be announced that
evening our political correspondent Liz
Bates has the latest on the race uh just
trust a warning there is some flash
Photography in her report
he's out of the race Boris Johnson never
officially entered but the prospect of
his return to Downing Street has
dominated this latest leadership contest
last night one of his team broke the
news outside what had become Campaign
Headquarters he's doing things in the
country's interest he's a great man out
there hard to not being united how bad
is it
in a statement Bush Johnson insisted
that he did have the numbers to win but
he said in the course of the last few
days I have sadly come to the conclusion
that this would simply not be the right
thing to do you can't govern effectively
unless you have a United party in
Parliament he added I believe I have
much more to offer but I'm afraid that
this is simply not the right time
that leaves the way clear for his rival
Rishi sunak always the front runner with
conservative MPS now looking likely to
become the next prime minister last
night he tweeted Boris Johnson delivered
brexit and the great vaccine rollout he
led our country through some of the
toughest challenges we have ever faced
and then took on Putin and his barbaric
war in Ukraine we will always be
grateful to him for that although he has
decided not to run for PM again I truly
hope he continues to contribute to
public life at home and abroad
but there's one more candidate he needs
to beat penny mordent has struggled to
be seen in this race now there are many
more votes up for grabs could she make
the ballot as well yesterday she was
insisting she's still a serious
Contender what this country needs is a
fresh face someone that can unite the
conservative party and get things to
work in this country
Boris Johnson's departure has cast a
shadow over this contest but today
attention turns to the two that remain
and who will take over at number 10 Liz
Bates Sky News Westminster
our political correspondent Mario Aurora
is here with me in Downing Street this
morning Mike good to see you I mean come
on what in Earth is going on it's 24
hours Boris Johnson look we're
describing his decision to bow out of
the race this morning as shocking but
what was it truly I mean if he didn't
have the numbers and if he couldn't have
persuaded either of the other two
candidates to give him a job and what
else was he going to do well exactly and
I think a lot of skeptical heads are
actually saying it wasn't necessarily a
massive surprise no one expected George
Boris Johnson to stay in the race unless
he felt he had a guaranteed win and with
what he was saying in his uh as his
statement 102 he said he had that's
really kind of scraping it just there
and imagine if a couple of people
changed their mind it could be quite a
tight squeeze of restaurants and I think
maybe he just didn't want to feel to
take that risk and their potential risk
of humiliation also I think there were
some really kind of final Nails in the
coffins we had swella bravaman a huge
ERG figure coming out for Rishi soon
like we had Kenny badnock a rising star
in the party also coming out
across Steve Baker you know some of this
really kind of big right-wing
heavyweights not backing Boris Johnson I
think for him maybe the writing was on
the wall and then we know in the
telegraph this morning we have uh Jeremy
Hunt the current Chancellor who's
written backing with and he said in the
telegraph with Richie sunac we have
someone who in our best Traditions will
turn the page on what went wrong take
decisions in the National interest and
rebuild the extraordinary potential of
our economy voters of all parties know
this perfectly well they are hoping and
praying We Choose Wisely we must not let
them down so is it all done and dusted
then well it's not all done and dusted
yet because Penny Morden we still don't
know whether maybe she can make a
miraculous comeback at the moment she's
on quite low figures she's hoping she
can scoop up a bunch of Boris Johnson
supporters is that a natural harm for
anyone who supported Boris Johnson I
think the issue with Boris Johnson
supporters is you would think Penny
Warden would be more of a natural home
especially if they still felt like Rishi
suno was a Brutus character the issue is
at the moment so many Boris backers have
now gone to uh Richardson you know Grant
chaps the current
um the current Home Secretary sorry he's
going to be on the show talking to you a
little bit later he was a massive
Borough supporter now look at him he's
with Rishi sunak so it doesn't seem like
everyone's doing the natural thing in
politics and that's really I think where
maybe Boris Johnson came unstuck I mean
but just to just to reflect on where we
are at the moment still of course the
throes of a cost of living crisis I mean
you know whoever becomes the next leader
of the conservative party the next prime
minister they need to hit the grounds
not as less trust is great I've actually
hit the ground and start running this
type yeah I mean there's so much to be
done we should not forget the fact that
this has now been dragging on for what
the best part four or five months well
this is the thing and I think voters are
going to start to have very very thin
patients with the Tory party we had this
you know Summer Leadership race that
some would say was a slight kind of
Naval gazing egocentric vanity project
I think so and then we've had Liz truss
and the chaos that ensued with Liz
truss's mini budget and then the pound
falling and crashing and the economy not
doing so well now we've got another
leadership race again more Naval gazing
when people are struggling worrying
about blackouts worrying about heating
their homes I think the public just want
to see some level of stability and
consistency and I think whoever ends up
winning this race it looks like it might
be Richie sunac they are going to have a
huge job on their hands not just to
control the economy and get things back
to go back to moving actually deal with
NHS backlog deal with you know social
care that now that ni Levy is being
scrapped there's so much it's such a
heavy entry for the next prime minister
and even Rishi sunak with all of his
credentials and popularity is going to
struggle well fingers crossed someone
will actually get on with the job at
some point soon I know thanks very much
indeed let's take you through the
morning's papers very quickly and we
should start today with the telegraph
you know it reports as we have been that
Rishi sunak is set to become the next PM
as Boris Johnson pulls out of the
leadership race
a similar headline on the front of the
times
sunak is set for number 10 as Johnson
quits race
not the right time reads the guardian
also reporting on Boris Johnson's
announcements that he wouldn't be
running for conservative leader
the Sun goes with Bojo it's a no and
bought a steps aside to avoid chaos
and on the front of the Daily Mail Rishi
set for number 10 as Boris bows out
lots and lots coming up on the show this
morning including this the Home
Secretary and of course Rishi sunak
supported Grand chaps and he will be
joining me in just a few minutes time
I'll also be getting from a supporter of
Penny Morgan's the veteran Tori MP so
Roger Gayle
and then in the eight o'clock shadow
attorney general Emily Thornbury will be
joining me
[Music]
some other news now and North and South
Korea have exchanged warning shots along
their disputed Western sea boundary
joining us from bangkoks guys Asia
correspondents I do they're always good
to see you and just how concerned should
we be about this there is always saber
rattling between the North and the South
indeed there is and this is indicative
of a ratcheting up of tension recently I
mean you're seeing both sides accuse
each other of breaching these Maritime
borders on one side you have South Korea
that's saying a North Korean vessel had
gone into this boundary area and they in
turn
fired a warning shot North Korea saying
exactly the same that it was a South
Korean vessel and they in turn uh fired
warning shots back I think the broader
context that's important to see Neil in
all of this is really in the past few
weeks we have seen North Korea carry out
a series of moves they say in response
to what they believe are offensive
military drills being carried out joint
military drills between South Korea and
the presence of some U.S military in
those as well they say it is really a
simply defensive preparation if you like
the bigger picture of this where South
Korea and its allies are particularly
concerned at the moment is they believe
that Kim Jong-un is nearing a possible
seventh nuclear test and we're seeing
three days of talks now going to be
conducted between South Korea and the us
as well so I think there is concern that
Kim Jong-un there is a certain sort of
Tide here this is a critical juncture
point one of as you say many that we
have seen occur between North and South
Korea but it's about that nuclear
capacity at the speed the force the
intent behind it
Cordelia many thanks indeed
well Ukraine's president has asked his
people to conserve electricity after
Russian missile strikes damaged around a
third of the nation's power stations our
Europe correspondent Adam Parsons joins
us now thank you Adam good to talk to
you this morning just describe what it
has been like at the lights going off so
quickly
yeah it's a gloomy morning actually here
in cave getting back to normal but it
comes after the latest evening and night
of rolling blackouts I think that's
what's noticeable that this starts
pretty much as the rush hour of people
returning home comes into effect and you
notice all little things there are
lights that have been turned off by the
side of the street when people return
home they don't know what is going to be
ahead of them or the electricity Beyond
will it be not it's something of a
random question one building may have it
you're the neighboring building may not
and I think that makes people a bit
nervous about what lies ahead of them
and as ever in Ukraine there is a
balance between this this seam of
stoicism and resilience and the reality
that what is happening there to them is
pretty miserable Russian air attacks
wiping out a big chunk of the energy
production infrastructure yet another
travial another suffering for the people
of Ukraine
Nina has come home to Darkness
earlier this year her apartment was
damaged by shrapnel now she's the victim
of a power cut
the electricity has been off for four
hours she's got no heating she can't
cook food
and winter is coming
foreign
Optimist yeah
but even in this resilient country
bravado does butt against cruel reality
Ukraine has to ration its electricity
and that creates misery
cassenya is a teacher with a young
family and she is desperately anxious
in our house we haven't got electric
cooker so I've got a little child I
can't cook feed him
it's very bad I can't walk because I
work my work is online I work online I I
need electricity but I haven't so at the
end of this month I hope I will I can
earn money to buy food for my family
the traffic lights still work but the
streets are dark light is precious here
[Music]
why
Russia has spent a week attacking power
stations like this one in Kiev
around a third of Ukraine's power
generation has been damaged
the government says people must use less
electricity and so the lights are turned
out
these power Cuts come without any
warning a couple of minutes ago that
block was lit up now the only sources of
light are coming from torches candles
and people's mobile phones and the other
problem that the residents there face is
that their heating is run by electricity
and temperatures here are dipping
the people of Ukraine are being pushed
and tested every day
they do cope they are proud
daily life here can be exhausting Adam
Parsons Sky News Keith
and it isn't just of course the impact
on on residential life in Ukraine when
you uh when you imperil electricity
Supply you've had a manifold effects you
affect a nation's industry so that that
industrial base that economic base that
that is trying to keep Ukraine going of
course you affect that the military
response but I think probably when
Russia looks at this one of its great
thoughts will be to try and depress
morale in Ukraine and of course that is
one of the things that has kept this
country together over the the past eight
months or so so far I personally don't
see any sign of ukrainians tumbling or
succumbing to that threat and president
zielinski has made it clear that he
thanks each and every person who is
responding to this restoring electricity
everyone he says they will take time
Adam thank you
let's stick with Ukraine for a moment
Britain France and the United States
have accused Russia of making
transplantly false claims that Ukraine
is plotting to use a dirty bomb on its
own territory the countries have issued
a rare joint statement saying that the
world would see through the allegations
last night Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski well he also responded to
Russia's claims
IA is
wherever Russia has brought death and
degradation we are returning normal life
that is precisely what Ukraine is about
where Ukraine is life is never destroyed
but wherever Russia arrives it leaves
behind Mass Graves torture camps
destroyed cities and Villages mined land
destroyed infrastructure and natural
disasters therefore when today the
Russian Minister of Defense organizes a
phone Carousel and calls foreign
ministers with stories about the
so-called dirty nuclear bomb everyone
understands everything well
let's take a quick look at some of the
day's other headlines now and more than
15 000 ambulance workers across 11
trusts in England and Wales start voting
today on whether to strike overpay
members of the GMB Union are being
balloted in the coming weeks the union
well it says its members are angry over
the government's four percent pay award
which is below inflation
the U.S House of Representatives
committee looking into the January 6th
Capital rights it's expected to ban any
live showing of Donald Trump's evidence
the committee's vice chair there's
Cheney said she didn't want the former
president's testimony to turn into a
televised food fight
foreign
mining painting has been covered in
mashed potatoes in the latest food
related climate protest members of a
German Environmental Group targeted the
painting in the Potsdam Museum yesterday
in protest against a fossil fuel
extraction this comes just a week after
two just stop oil protesters through
tomato soup over Van Gogh's sunflowers
at the National Gallery in London
they're not just 100 days left to use up
your stamps that don't have a barcode
after the 31st of January these Stamps
will no longer be valid for postage
anyone unable to use the older everyday
Stamps will however be able to exchange
them for newer barcoded ones
uh heavy rain and thunderstorms have
battered parts of Southern England
overnight causing flooding and
disrupting travel a yellow weather
warning was in fact in place until two
o'clock this morning in many areas
including bath Brighton and London and
today the southeast is bracing itself
for heavy thunderstorms on a second day
of warnings from the Met Office
appropriately enough time for the
weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
and the next few days will be unsettled
with showers or more persistent rain
some heavy and thundering it will
however be mostly dry and Mild at first
today although a bit cooler than
yesterday there will be showers around
mainly in the north and near southern
and western coasts
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
our let's return though to the
conservative leadership contest and
Rishi sunak is now the clear
front-runner after Boris Johnson quit
the race last night it leaves Penny
mordant as the only other candidate to
publicly stand against the former
Chancellor joining us now on the program
the Home Secretary and of course the
supporter of Rishi sunac Grand chaps Mr
Sharps very good morning to you um
you're practically a brand ambassador
for Excel these days so do tell me what
did the spreadsheet say about the
veracity of Boris Johnson's claim to
have 102 102 nominations
well it won't surprise you to learn that
since I became um Home Secretary last
week actually my head has been buried in
counterterrorism briefings uh security
briefings and other things so I have not
actually been able to perform uh that
role I've been looking after the the
Safety and Security of the country
instead
um but uh you know I saw Boris Johnson's
um statement last night he said he had
uh the numbers but in the interest of
both party unity and the country uh he
said he would withdraw and I have to say
I think he did the right thing I think
that is that sensible under the
circumstances I think Boris Johnson was
uh you know actually in many ways
a very impressive uh prime minister what
with his response to getting beyond the
brexit thing the covered vaccine roll
out his responses so why not know that I
think he did a lot of good things
for him to be able to I was going to say
I think you're probably a bit too early
for him to make a return there's still
that parliamentary investigation uh
outstanding and I think he recognized
that actually within the Parliamentary
party so in other words within
conservative MPS uh probably it was just
too soon to be returning to the fold
without some of these other matters
resolves and so I think that's why he
decided not to go again but I I think
actually you know as a party we think
that there are a lot of very very good
things he did but he's recognized that
through the unity of the the country and
now is not the time and I think that's
why he withdrew
should we take it from what you've sent
then that you're now calling on Penny
Morton to do the same and step aside
you know I know it's up to her but what
do you think should she do it or not
yeah well I was going to I was going to
say what I do know is that Rishi enjoys
the support of a large number of uh
conservative MPS and there's a very high
nomination threshold of a hundred so
um you know
putting it the other way around really
she doesn't think that it's in the bag
he's speaking to colleagues this morning
he's working very hard to attract those
supporters who were perhaps with Boris
Johnson uh previously
um but I mean look I'll leave it to
Penny she's a terrific colleague let's
see what happens but we won't have to
wait very long because by this lunch
time I think specifically two o'clock we
will know the answer to all of this and
we'll see whether it does indeed go to a
second round which means out to the
membership in the country or whether
indeed it's all over at that stage but
nothing taken taken for granted by Rishi
at this stage I mean you and of course
you're a transport secretary under Boris
Johnson you then supported Rishi sunat
during his well the previous failed bid
to become leader uh you're now home
secretary under uh Liz truss uh I mean
the only person you haven't supported is
Penny Morton I mean aren't we just in a
kind of a position at the moment right
now where you have to take you at your
word that you believe that Rishi sunak
is the best candidate despite the fact
you've worked for no plenty of other
people as well
well I'm very grateful to uh the the uh
to Liz trust for uh appointed Me Home
Secretary of course is incredibly
important job looking after you know the
security of the of the nation in so many
different ways uh as you already pointed
out I didn't actually support Liz truss
I did support Rishi sonnet so I mean to
be honest becoming homesick actually in
her government does strike me as a
fairly much a statement of support
well look I just actually I'm coming
old-fashioned but I just think it's a
matter of public service and and Duty uh
we're living in incredibly uh dangerous
times uh we've got this war in Ukraine
and all the spin-off from that Homeland
Security and what's happening in this
country uh enormously important I'm here
in my constituency in Welling Garden
right now and uh you know I know that
what people want is safety on the
streets security at home and I think
that the job of of Home Secretary is a
very very important role to fulfill so
you know I I there's no politics
involved in making sure that we're doing
a good job on the most basic things that
a government must do which is look after
its people and its borders and that's
why I was uh pleased to accept the
position of of Home Secretary but as you
rightly point out I supported Rishi
sunac in the summer because I thought
that economically he understood what
this country uh needed and obviously
improve right uh look what's happened
since
well just just on that point how much do
you know of the strategy the economic
strategy that Rishi sunlight will be
coming forward I mean for example
National Insurance should we expect to
see it going back up again
no that's been voted through uh and uh
Rishi said he would leave that as things
are now and actually he set out a very
detailed program uh through all of those
weeks of the leadership contest in the
summer so unfortunately we know a lot
about what he'd do of course the main
thing is we know how he performed as
Chancellor through the coronavirus
pandemic as well so you know actually we
can be pretty sure about the way he'll
behave it's very straightforward he'll
he'll Bear Down on inflation he'll get
growth in the economy and he'll reduce
taxes but it'll do it in that order
which I think is really important
because that's what gives security and
confidence to the markets and therefore
to the population
sure but it isn't no potentially the
time for this to all be put to the
public once again you know four Prime
Ministers and not very long to suggest
that perhaps there isn't the Mandate
there for Rishi sunak that there was
previously I mean the last uh totally
leadership election was decided by party
members representing about 0.3 of the
electorate this time the leadership's
being decided by you and your colleagues
who represent I might just work this out
not Point not not not not seven percent
of the electorate 700 000 of one percent
surely it is no time to let the British
public have a bit of a say in who
actually runs this country
well so I'm standing here in my
constituency uh well in Hatfield I'm in
well in Garden City and every single
person uh had the opportunity here to
vote I'm very grateful they elected me
last time around in 2019. I haven't
changed and I'm still here and the same
is the case in 650 constituencies around
the country we elect a party and we
elect uh individuals as members of that
party and the 2019 Manifesto is actually
the thing the document if you like that
Rishi is standing on so none we don't
tend to have four prime ministers in
three years though
uh of course it's unusual I I I give you
that but one of those Prime Ministers is
one who's elected with that Manifesto of
course so you're slightly playing
figures there but but nonetheless the
individuals who were elected and I was
on the ballot paper are still the same
individuals who are in place and there's
a five-year program and we will be
delivering that Manifesto now you're
absolutely right the beans and bumps not
just change in prime ministers but uh
also covid also the war in Ukraine along
the way so it has been a very very uh
difficult period but the manifesto is
the manifesto and that is primarily if
you want to see what Rishi is going to
be doing it's all there
I mean all of that would make sense if
the previous prime minister hadn't was
in fact the current prime minister I
should say it hadn't torn up the 2019
Manifesto and danced on its grave I mean
the point I'm trying to make is we have
been through so many iterations of the
conservative party recently that whilst
you're absolutely right there is nothing
constitutionally wrong with what is
happening at the moment you might
suggest that the public should have a
bit of a say in this I mean think of it
this way isn't it simply the case that
because you know Rishi sunak you know
isn't even popular with the conservative
party membership in a leadership contest
he can't get the conservatives to vote
for him in a leadership contest What
chan says they're of them voting Forum
in a general election isn't that what's
at stake here the Electoral Oblivion
that the conservative party faces if you
are bold enough to call a general
election
also I mean it's but actually I I think
the way you describes it quite quite
it's quite interesting because there
wasn't a sense an Excursion a diversion
uh from the 2019 Manifesto in some ways
particularly in in terms of uh tax
policy and fiscally
um over the uh the last couple of months
uh which will be now returning to you
know what we said we should do all along
which is make sure that we run a
responsible economy that the you know
for example as things stand at the
moment inflation is born down on we get
economic growth and then we can reduce
taxes but you've got to do it in that
order and so actually in a way this is
more authentic to the 2019 Manifesto and
anyway either way after five years
people get to judge
um the the the the the the outcome of
the votes that they place I don't
disagree that
um you know there is a lot to do and a
lot to prove we've had all the
distractions of coronavirus we've got
the war in Ukraine causing that
inflation but in two years time voters
around here in well in Hatfield around
the country they'll be able to make
their decisions known and they'll be
able to do it based on the 2019
Manifesto did we deliver it did we are
they content with that and they'll be
able to make their minds up so so look I
I I think we can we can wait to see uh
in the meantime I'm very hopeful that
Richard will be successful but we'll
have to wait and see at least until this
lunch time and maybe longer to find out
um Minister just a final couple of
questions genuinely what has been the
point of the conservative party for the
last three months
well look I I didn't I didn't vote for
what we've had over the the last uh
couple of months I think it is since
your colleagues did that's the point
this has been in power because I was
well mostly MPS didn't it was it you as
you rightly pointed out
um that the view was taken in the
country amongst the membership
membership uh to go in a certain
direction I think it's fair to say that
it hasn't worked and the current prime
minister has acknowledged that and of
course resigned as a result I think this
is the opportunity to make sure that we
are the parts of the stumbles
conservatives have always done looked
after you know the the pound in your
pocket looked after the the country
financially we come back to the same
question you've just conceded you've
just conceded that it didn't work that
Liz trust didn't work you know the
conservative party pooped her and it
should be trusted conservative party
again
exactly yeah and she could she she said
the same thing herself but but look what
I would say is actually uh interestingly
and it happened during uh Liz's uh time
in Downing Street we hit the lowest
unemployment that this country has seen
since
1973 and conservatives as ever are the
of the party of high employment low
unemployment and that's something that's
very good that's happened so I think you
know it's not it's not the case that
that everything has been uh everything
has been bad level's important are
incredibly important but I think as Liz
truss accepted herself that the
experiment with reducing taxes and doing
that on borrowing does not work and it's
it's a good reason to put that right
very quickly as I say I think Rishi has
the right plan for that he's proven as a
Chancellor and he was right about
everything that he said in the summer
about what would happen if you tried to
go down that route which is why I think
it's uh he's the right person to to lead
this country
Grant chaps always good to talk to you
thanks for joining us this morning on
breakfast
[Music]
as you can see our political
correspondent Mari Arora is glued to the
street here in Danish this morning and
what did we make of that and like maybe
obviously we had to kind of push him on
a few points but he's absolutely
convinced and with good reason that his
man's going to be the next prime
minister
izing although obviously as we know when
Boris was in the in the running we
thought maybe people did it well it
didn't go well and then he was kind of
out in the cold and now he's been
brought back into cabinet under Liz
trust now he was very very keen to
stress he didn't vote for this trust he
didn't vote for what Liz trust stood for
and what he called it the you know the
diversion from the 2019 Manifesto the
experiment he liked to call it of Liz
truss's mini budget and fiscal plans it
was very very eager to distance himself
but I think it was interesting when you
pushed him on the fact that he accepted
a job under Liz truss despite the fact
that he disagreed with basically
everything she stood for and he was
slightly squirmish about how to wiggle
out of that question because it is quite
difficult when you're serving under a
prime minister that you really don't
believe in at all which I thought was
really really interesting now he talked
about how Boris Johnson's decision to
pull out was sensible and it was too
early and he very kind of explicitly
mentioned that partygate Pro and how
that's going to be a big issue obviously
we've had some reports in the papers
this morning that the project Escape
probe could end up potentially
encircling which you still like as well
if he's brought in as part of that so
his his guy could end up being kind of
enthralled in that too which means he
could end up eating his uh his words
magic thanks very much for that man it's
Monday morning you've already depressed
me thank you again uh plenty more coming
up from here in dining Street this
morning we will be speaking to
representative of the penny margin
campaign to find out whether or not she
will be stepping aside to do stick with
us get on breakfast
[Music]
welcome back to Downing Street well of
course in the next few hours we could
see an announcement which sees our next
prime minister uh coming in at Rishi
sunai clearly the front runner Penny
Warden does remain in the contest but
trailing in terms of numbers the short
news of the fast 24 hours well the shock
to some at least was that Boris Johnson
was not going to be standing primarily a
shocking fact to people like Nadeem
sarawi who we're going to have on the
show this morning at defending the Prime
Minister defending Boris Johnson's
campaign to become Prime Minister we
think that around about two o'clock
today if and unless uh Penny modern does
not get past that hundred nominations
required at Rishi sunak will be the next
prime minister and of course leader of
the conservative party but there is a
lot of other news around today and we
should focus on that for a while and you
covered and flu vaccine campaign has
launched today
urging Millions to boost their
immunities we head into winter those
with long-term health conditions and
pregnant women are among those being
encouraged to come forward let's speak
now to Dr Thomas Waite the deputy chief
medical officer for England Dr Wayne
lovely to have you on the program this
morning um do tell us just a little bit
more about this campaign why the push
and who's it being focused on
level 10 million people have come
forward and had a covert booster already
this awesome which is a great start to
the to the campaign but that leaves many
many people still to come forward
everybody aged 50 and over people with a
range of health conditions heart
conditions kidney conditions lung
conditions and so on as well as pregnant
women and I've got a great range of
carers paid and arm painter all eligible
so please do come forward you can get a
vaccine by booking online by dialing 119
or going to a walk-in center near you if
that's convenient but now is a really
good time to boost your immunity which
will cover you for Christmas New Year
and into 2023.
uh we'll talk to what then is the level
of immunity that people like myself will
have who had their their shot and then
their booster and so on I mean at some
point those outside of these kind of
groups are they going to be focused on
are they going to be receiving a booster
because it kind of feels like we're
being left out
so the reason for the focus on people
aged 50 and over is that age is by far
the biggest predictor of severe illness
for kovid this year the vaccine that's
being offered to people age 50 and older
and the at-risk groups is what's called
a bivalence vaccine that means it covers
two different types of coronavirus the
original type as well as the Omicron
type and thus reduces the risk of
getting the really severe consequences
we saw with lots of people ending up in
hospital before the rollout of vaccines
vaccines have saved many lives both for
flu and for covert over the years so
this is a good time to come forward and
top up your immunity before winter
still I mean the data currently is is
pretty concerning more than 50 000
people in England testing positive over
the last seven days a further 786 deaths
I mean personally doctor I mean how
concerned are you
so those are the fact that the figures
for covert that you've mentioned and
we're also seeing an uptick and flu
we've seen flu start to increase in
children as well as in all other age
groups and in a typical flu year before
the pandemic we saw four to maybe as
high as 20 000 deaths from flu per year
in addition to 40 000 or so
hospitalizations from flu or
complications due to that so there are a
number of reasons to be concerned but
the vaccines are very effective and are
our best way of protecting ourselves
from ending up in hospital this winter
reports that I read this weekend some
some privately run Care Homes are
apparently restricting people from
visiting their elderly relatives now
this of course despite the fact that
government regulations uh have all
restrictions have already been lifted I
mean what is your view on that and and
is it legal
so everybody in a care home is eligible
for both a flu vaccine and a coronavirus
vaccination if there are outbreaks going
on of a number of different diseases not
just respiratory illnesses then it's
fairly common practice to restrict
visiting or put in a number of other
ways to try and protect the spread of
infectious disease from one person to
another but again if you're going to see
somebody who you know is vulnerable or
you know is older if you've got symptoms
of respiratory infection the best thing
to do is to wait a few days for your
symptoms to pass before you go out uh go
go back out it's a really easy way to
prevent the transmission to older people
alongside things like making sure we're
washing our hands vaccines protect
ourselves but the sort of steps we can
take basic hygiene that we're all used
to from before the pandemic help protect
each other
are argues and anticipating door to it
I'm a broader set of restrictions on
Care Homes the likes of which we saw
during the previous peaks of Coronavirus
I think that's extremely unlikely
because we've come a long way since 2020
when we didn't have vaccines and when
very few of us had any immunity and all
of the research studies and people
who've given their blood during which to
sort of help us understand the
transmission of diseases shows us that
by far the best way of topping up your
immunity is vaccines and in fact the
best way of predicting whether or not
people have immunity is understanding
whether they've been vaccinated or not
so vaccines will help have got us this
far further boosters this winter will
help the most vulnerable people get the
best protection and that's why we're
calling on people to come forward now
it's half term that's a good time for
some people to get vaccinated and get
both your flu and your covert job in
some places you can get both at the same
time that's safe and effective and if
that suits you it's a really good time
to do it
Dr Thomas wait great to have you on the
program this morning thanks for being
with me thank you
no since taking office back in 2019
Brazil's Brazil's president Jared
boltonaro has issued more than a dozen
decrees loosening restrictions on gun
ownership for civilians the far-right
politician who faces a tough re-election
battle later this week has courted
Brazil's growing gun lobby and often
posies for photos making a gun sign with
his thumb and forefinger and he claims
his left-wing challenge or Lula de Silva
will crack down on gun ownership if he
wins the upcoming election
uh well it's also stalked fears of
post-election violence in the country
our chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey
reports now from Sao Paulo
it's a big booming growth sector and
it's another key issue in this
desperately tight election battle
private gun ownership has rocketed under
Brazil's right-wing president chair
bolsonaro
he and his supporters contest that
bearing arms is a fundamental right
although unlike the United States this
isn't actually mentioned in Brazil's
Constitution
a day out at the assault shooting range
is something of a family affair and all
the generations take part
the assault club's owner has no doubt
that anything but a bolsonaro win will
be bad for him
there is a fear in Brazil that bolsonaro
supporting groups will fashion
themselves on America's Trump supporting
gun carriers
that fear highlighted by the closeness
of the election and the threat of
electoral linked violence
before President boltonaro Brazil was
not a country Awash with legally held
weapons but things have certainly
changed and in fact as part of his
election campaign he's actually said to
his supporters to take up arms to avoid
inflation he's yet another controversial
issue of the many in this election
a new group of would-be gun owners
attend their first class they're taught
through the handling and firing of
weapons
it's estimated that this year a thousand
people signed up to qualify for permits
every single day
president bolsonaro has used executive
powers to relax the country's previously
stringent gun laws imposed by his
electoral adversary Lula de Silva
with it a multi-million pound business
has thrived
this gun shop clears 1.7 million pounds
each month
the Shop's owner showed bolsonaro
supporting Senator George a sief and me
a weapon that he has imported from his
Factory in Israel would you like one
sure
for example Senator Thief says that if
bolsonaro wins it will change the gun
laws forever yeah
Lula and his supporters say that having
more guns in a country that already has
a terrible record for crime is at best
Reckless
the bolsonaro followers disagree arguing
that guns allow people to protect
themselves
like so many things in this election
they will never agree
Stu Ramsay Sky News Sao Paulo
shall we and of course Rishi sunak get
me a past that threshold all-important
threshold of a hundred nominations from
MPS but the only remaining Contender
given that Boris Johnson has not thrown
his hat into the ring at Penny modern
well she's certainly got some catching
up to do one of those in her Corner sir
Roger Gale joined us on the program so
Roger a very good morning to you um
let's start shall we if we can with with
Boris Johnson not as mentioned at
throwing his hat into the ring was there
an inevitability about that Good Morning
Neil yes I think there was uh there was
a harsh difference of reality between
the beaches of Dominica and uh the
atmosphere in Westminster and I think Mr
Johnson came back
discovered that he did not have the
overwhelming support of the
Parliamentary party never mind people in
the country
and made the right decision for himself
for his country
and of course for the conservative party
given that the penny Morgan has this
morning been been praising Boris Johnson
on Twitter for doing the honorable thing
for putting country ahead of personal
priorities putting a country ahead of
party and stepping aside given where
she's at in terms of the numbers is no
not perhaps the point that Penny mordant
consider as her own position
where she's at in terms of the numbers
is not I think quite um where with
respect reports are saying
um I saw a penny where are they then sir
Roger
I beg your pardon
go and tell me where are the numbers how
many is she gone
I'm not privy to that information but uh
I Saw Penny about 20 minutes ago and she
said we're in the zone and look Neil I
think what is important is that we do
have the choice put before members of
parliament and then before the country
I'm fairly relaxed about this well not
before the country it's a Roger before
the conservative party membership the
two are really different but before them
all right fine before the conservative
party membership in the country but
we've got a team of people now penny
mordant
um Jeremy Hunt has the chance of the
exchequer Ben Wallace who is Prosecuting
a war in Ukraine and Rishi sunak who is
indubitably talented and I think between
them in whatever order those four people
will unite our party the country and
take us forward to where we need to be
and that is what really matters in the
National interest
s so what then in your view would be
lost by this being a Richie sunac
coronation without the membership being
given the opportunity to have their say
I'm not a great fan of coronations they
uh well not political coronations they
tend to unravel and I think it is
important that the Parliamentary party
has a choice and that the membership of
the country as you've said rightly
corrected me has a has a choice whatever
that choice is I will and I'm sure that
the overwhelming majority
of the Parliamentary party and party
members will rally behind whoever
emerges as the leader because that's
what we've got to do but penny is a
great team player and a great team
leader and that's really why I'm
supporting her she's got immense
capacity to bring people together
indeed but perhaps it get given the way
in which the membership viewed Rishi
suna's last attempt to become a leader
of the party presumably I'm taking from
what you're saying you don't feel that
he would be capable of uniting the party
I'd like the membership to have a
straightforward choice between two
people Penny Morton and Rishi sunak and
I would hope and expect
that not only I
um but all the members and I've been a
member of the party for before since
before Boris Johnson was born actually
um I think I would hope and expect that
we will all rally behind whoever emerges
as the leader because we've got a job of
work to do and that's what matters what
matters is is the people of this country
it's real people's real lives is
mortgages his interest rates is the cost
of living those are the things we've got
to deal with
but but that has that has been the case
since the start of the last leadership
contest I mean I put a similar question
to Grant chaps a little earlier but what
has been the point of this conservative
government for the past three months
I think we've come very seriously off
the rails in the last three months we
have to get back on track Jeremy Hunters
made a very good start in repairing some
of the damage that has been done there's
a heck of a lot more work to do quite
clearly and we needed the right team of
people to do that and the right team
leader to lead the team but it can be
done and I have every confidence that it
will be done
what happened in that meeting between
Penny Morton and Boris Johnson I mean
did she offer him something to get him
to step aside to give her perhaps some
of her some of his nominations
I I was not a fly on the wall in that
meeting any more than you were Nile and
I don't know but knowing penny
who is very straight talking indeed I
think she will have simply said I'm
sorry that is not a game that I am
prepared to play
um that negotiation was never really a
starter but as courtesy she took the
call
tell me then why you believe so firmly
that that penny more than who does not
have an overwhelming CV in terms of in
terms of a party experience experience
in high office why you feel that penny
more than should be the next prime
minister I think that's if I may say so
more than a little unfair she's held
nine ministerial posts she was Secretary
of State for overseas development which
requires considerable degree of empathy
and and understanding she was then
Secretary of State for defense which is
no mean task in itself
as the president of the privy Council
she showed great dignity following the
death of her majesty at the accession
council and managed that I think
superbly she's handled her role as
leader of the House very well indeed she
stood in for the Prime Minister on a
rather Sticky Wicket last week and
demonstrated
how she is capable of managing the house
managing business and bringing people
together I think that's inside
that she wasn't hiding under a desk no I
don't think she did at all I know the
Press made a great deal of that but she
simply threw back at Stella Creasy what
Stella Creasy threw at her
and and just a final thought from you
sir Roger genuinely I mean with your
experience do you think that the
conservative party can come back from
this given the absolute paroxysms it's
been in for the past three months yes I
do absolutely and I am heartily relieved
Neil that uh I can now say with total
confidence and honesty I will support
whoever emerges as the leader and I
couldn't have said that 24 hours ago
so Roger always a pleasure to talk to
you thanks very much for joining us at
this morning on breakfast
I will stay right where you are as
indeed I will be doing alongside uh
Mario Roda coming up in the next hour we
will have the very latest in the race to
become the next prime minister I'll be
getting Labor's take with the shadow
attorney general Emily Thornbury and we
will be reflecting on the facts that in
a few short hours we might yet have a
new another new prime minister see after
this
[Music]
thank you